et bien bonjour bonne année même si ça
fait déjà plusieurs jours que c'était la
nouvelle année les amis j'espère que
vous allez bien moi ça j'allais venir je
suis extrêmement malade je vous avoue je
voulais tourner sur getting over it pour
finir le jeu et je crois que la maladie
tombe au bon moment parce que j'aurai
tout simplement fait une crise de nerfs
le 25 juin j'avais fait une vidéo qui
parlait de mes trois cent soixante
derniers jours sur youtube est en fait
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de refaire la
même chose déjà parce que je crois que
suis dans l'incapacité de faire autre
chose et ensuite parce que moment où
j'ai fait cette vidéo là je pouvais pas
me douter que ce qui allait suivre
allait être encore plus dingue ces six
derniers mois sur youtube ont été
incroyables que ce soit en terme de
rencontres ou en termes d'épanouissement
personnel le 1er juillet je sortais sur
ma chaîne le clip placement de produit
avec maxence qui est vraiment devenu un
très bon ami en fait jacques énormément
d'expérience quand j'ai bossé sur les
vidéos 20 watts rap battle que ce soit
avec pivi nova ou avec jules fou avec
nos des d'ailleurs c'est la vidéo la
plus vite 2007 en france donc merci
beaucoup et ça fait plaisir à toutes les
personnes qui ont bossé sur le projet
donc voila merci après ça j'avais acquis
l'expérience nécessaire pour faire une
musique moi même mais je voulais pas
faire ça seul voulu que ce soit un
délire de potes donc j'avais contacté
max ans qui était hyper chaud par le
thème et par l'ambiance aussi du morceau
et puis on a fait ça et c'était génial
de semaine après je contacte big flo et
oli qui voulait trop qu'on fasse un truc
ensemble à l'occasion de la sortie de
leur album pour leur annoncer une idée
que j'ai eue qui serait juste de
sélectionner des mots au hasard dans un
dictionnaire et de devoir les caler dans
des couples et de rats il faut savoir
que c'est des mecs qui connaissent très
bien youtube y est mais qui sont très
gentils et il voulait déjà faire un
petit truc avec moi en 2015 donc je
l'avais invité à la fin d'une vidéo pour
faire un pareil un petit champ un petit
truc mais voilà les gens se souvient pas
de sa vidéo j'ai ça puisse y aussi big
three au lit l'album et là on a visé
haut ont démarché squeeze en fout le
bordel dans ta vidéo
comme lui car on peut rater nos âmes
trop faire le beau devant l'ordi avoir
la dalle comme jumbo
je sais on était jeunes quand tu
regardes ça ne fait pas très bien tu es
plutôt gênée on va pas se mentir mais en
tout cas c'était une trop bonne
rencontre on avait qui fait et on
s'était dit à l'époque
à la sortie de leur prochain album on
fera un vrai truc cool chose faite on
assortit cette vidéo là dans laquelle on
a déliré sur le bandeau à l'arrêt du
dictionnaire est à l' hyper bien marché
le concept vous a trop plus la suite
vous la connaissez deux mois après je le
redis les mecs ce qu'on a fait il ya
deux mois c'était génial j'ai trop envie
qu'on fasse la même en mieux en fait en
parallèle j'avais déjà contacté le petit
robert éditeur du dictionnaire qu'on
avait utilisé dans la première vidéo et
je leur avais demandé si c'était
possible d'avoir à lembeye et je crois
qu'il était en vacances en bretagne à ce
moment là donc je n'avais pas trop
encore eu de réponse est en fait big
fuel y ont eu la même idée que moi de le
ramener à lembeye et m'avait demandé mec
tu penses pas que peut nous ramener à
l'oreille j'avais tout donné pour pas
qu'ils grygera avait même fait croire
que à l'arrêt y avait trop mal pris le
fait qu'on se moque du bandeau et tout
et qu'on utilise sa tête alors qu'en
fait c'est faux j'ai une réponse sept
jours plus tard environ de l'éditeur qui
m'a dit bon bah alain il est hyper
partant il a adoré votre vidéo il a
adoré ce que vous avez fait il trouve ça
génial comme principe et ensuite je
représente ce fameux à l'arrêt ils
étaient bas voilà vous l'avez vu dans le
best-of ayad il ya quelques jours il
était vraiment sur le cul c'était trop
contents et à l'arrêt il est vraiment
excellent il est hyper compréhensif
attentif rigolo et c'est un grand
monsieur quoi franchement c'était un peu
comme c'était notre grand-père à nous
trois qui étaient venues et on a vu une
sorte de respect naturel pour lui et il
a un charisme
enfin c'était vraiment génial plus le
lendemain soir on sort le clip qu'on a
vraiment fait en une heure à larache on
sait que trois prises par plan séquence
fin bref et ben les gens vraiment aimé
le truc quoi et aujourd'hui c'est pareil
l'une des vidéos les plus vues de ma
chaîne 19 millions de vues je crois que
c'est la deuxième vidéo la plus vue de
ma chaîne a prouvé rouge donc c'est ouf
ces six derniers mois sur youtube sont
aussi ceux où j'ai fait le plus de
vidéos avec d'autres personnes que ce
soit avec mc fly carlito natu maxence
cyprien où j'ai vraiment fait énormément
de vidéo à plusieurs parce qu'en fait je
me suis rappelé que quand j'avais
commencé youtube à l'époque en 2011
c'était dans cette ambiance là j'ai
essayé de faire des trucs avec mes potes
du lycée de les ramener dans les vidéos
condé l'iran semblait en fait j'avais
perdu le truc là pendant deux ans et
j'ai envie je m'étais isolé je bossais
comme un chien je faisais quatre vidéos
par semaine et en fait j'avais
complètement oublié le pourquoi du je
suis sur youtube pourquoi je me suis mis
à faire ça et du coup ces six derniers
mois en fait ça a été une vraiment une
libération ça m'a fait énormément de
bien de faire des vidéos avec plein de
gens la meilleure chose c'est d'inviter
des potes en vidéo de délirer avec eux
parce qu'il ya une complicité il ya un
truc et les gens adorent
ça en fait voir des gens qui s'aiment
bien s'amuser entre eux se vanner et
tout et même moi j'ai pris un plaisir
monstrueux à faire un duo avec mac faye
karito c'était vraiment ma rencontre de
2010 aide ces deux personnes formidables
je les adore et m'ont beaucoup apporté
et c'est un peu mes grands frères et je
sais pas c'est une sorte de déclic
bizarre j'ai eu je me en fait souvent on
se prive de certaines choses parce qu'on
a peur parce qu'on n'ose pas parce qu'on
est vraiment dans notre zone de confort
et je pense qu'à un moment il faut aussi
se faire qu'il fait il faut oser faire
ce qu'on a vraiment envie de faire au
fond de nous et puis les réactions battu
voie après et il faut pas trop que ça te
tracasse quoi donc en parallèle de ce
délire là de faire des vidéos avec plein
de gens je me suis aussi cette année ça
c'est vraiment l'un des plus gros truc
qui s'est passé toutes ces dernières
années pour moi sur youtube s'est arrêté
de faire x nombre de vidéos par semaine
de me forcer à les faire et je pense que
la plupart des youtuber qui font
beaucoup de vidéos par semaine ont le
même problème en fait justice aux pattes
diminué ça peut être vraiment très
dangereux de continuer dans cette voie
là perso j'ai fait ça pendant deux ou
trois ans est en fait déjà sept isole
vachement parce que tu es devant son
ordi toute la journée à trouver qu'est
ce que tu vas faire le faire et ensuite
le monter le mettre en ligne
et ce à quatre fois par semaine alors il
ya pire dans la vie je suis d'accord
mais je pense que quand on est youtube
heures il ya tout pour être heureux et
c'est trop bête de gâcher le la joie en
s'imposant des trucs comme ça que
personne nous impose en plus c'est
complètement débile du coup sûr le
tournage mekla de plus j'ai plus envie
de le faire mais aussi au montage il se
passe un truc c'est que du coup il ya
moins de vidéos à monter donc quand on
monte une hta plus de temps et surtout
été plus épanoui dans sa vie parce que
tu passes un peu moins donc tu te lâche
un peu plus au montage sais pas si vous
saviez mais c'est pas moi qui monte mes
vidéos fin jean monde certaines n'est
pas tout du tout la plupart des vidéos
sont montés par clément clément qui est
mon monteur depuis maintenant deux ans à
dire vrai travail de création derrière
faut vraiment ajouter sa tâche au
montage sinon la vidéo est pas dingue
clément se donne de ouf
il craque complètement son slip et à
[ __ ] les vidéos sont géniales clément
/ hier cette vidéo et vu que c'est toi
qui vas la montée celle-là je sais que
tu la regardes est bien plein de gros
bisous à toi et gros love et en parlant
de clément j'étais très content parce
que en août je suis allé au canada pour
une opé par l'office du tourisme
canadien destination canada nous lâchait
cet accent ça m'a fait trop du bien pour
plusieurs raisons la première c'est que
je suis parti avec clément et en fait on
n'avait jamais passé beaucoup de temps
ensemble en fait moi je suis très
casanier très solitaire et clément il
est un peu pareil donc du coup on est
jamais y perd ensemble à se voir tous
les soirs et tous et ce truc là ça nous
a fait vivre ensemble pendant
sept jours mais de manière intense on a
fait des activités trop coulant sens
même si on bosse et on s'était quand
même hyper épanouissant et c'est
vachement l'approché donc je trouve que
c'était vraiment une bonne chose
ensuite au delà de ça j'ai pu rencontrer
mes fans du canada on voit très peu en
france parce qu'ils sont au canada et il
ya cette fameuse scène dont je crois le
deuxième blog où je vais une fête
foraine dans une ville du skull du
québec devra en tout petit et bien plein
de gens qui me reconnaissent ils étaient
tous trop sympa trouver tout et me voir
là j'étais aussi étonné de voir autant
de fans québécois je garde vraiment un
super souvenir de cette soirée à parler
[ __ ] de piqûres de moustiques qu'on
sait manger avec clément dans la grande
roue la la fin horrible mais qui avait
mis le moustique à tous les étages de la
rousse des horribles en tout cas les
québécois vous m'avez fait vraiment
chaud au coeur j'ai découvert un peu vos
traditions faux plat préféré votre
manière de vie votre joie de vivre
vraiment merci à tous ceux que j'ai
croisés là bas que je sois des abonnés
ou des gens qui nous ont aidé au long de
notre voyage c'était c'était fou et
voilà j'en ai gardé un souvenir à jamais
sur ma peau par david costumes à tatouer
et qui a aussi tatoué clément d'ailleurs
tous les voyages que j'ai pu faire mon
vraiment marqué et je me souviendrai
toute ma vie et le dernier que j'ai fait
était génial parce que c'était le japon
qui est mon pays préférés sur terre et
que j'ai pu adopter enfin un petit chiba
il nous c'est un truc que je rêvais de
faire depuis plusieurs années mais comme
je vous ai dit j'ai vraiment passé deux
ans la tête dans le travail à à tourner
et monter tout le temps quatre fois par
semaine j'avais vraiment aucun temps
même pour m'occuper jumbo j'avais peu de
temps c'était l'enfer du coup j'avais
reporter ce projet d'adopter un chien
parce que j'étais tout simplement pas
prêt et c'est une décision qu'il faut
prendre au sérieux et pas du tout à la
légère je veux au japon une première
fois je le vois tout petit il était
hyper contents de me voir alors qu'il me
connaissait même pas je comprends
toujours pas moi je vois un inconnu
arrivée mec je mens il lui me fait une
fête de foule le sort il court il vient
dans mes bras c'était dingue
je suis hyper gaga et des fois j'ai peur
je vous dis attend peut-être j'en fais
trop avec mon chien et tout mais c est
ce que c'est quand on aime quelqu'un ou
un animal eh ben on a envie de le
montrer quoi elle pas de se cacher en
expérience humaine on est aussi allé
dormir dans une forêt avec my swing dans
la nature on avait eu cette idée là
plusieurs mois avant qu'on ait visité
l'hôpital abandonné et ont cédé 10 mecs
ça serait trop marrant de faire une nuit
en forêt on va vraiment chier dessus et
ou alors final c'est pas du tout chier
dessus qui avait françois qui est tout
simplement un vétéran extrêmement fort
avec nous françois ya un an ce qui vient
il s'en bat les couilles il fait une clé
de bras à l'oci a plus aucun problème
françois tu es mon héros c'est marrant
parce que je regardais les émissions de
mamie twin qui a des années il faisait
des émissions sur jeuxvideo.com et par
les lords of warcraft et me dire que
quelques années après je me retrouve
avec ce mec en forêt en train de
faire un feu et de fabriquer un abri
jusqu'au ça génial mes meetings
provisions à toi novembre je sors mon
premier livre tourner la page fait avec
maxence et mon frère ça fait toujours
plaisir de sortir quelque chose où tu
sais que des gens vont être contents
d'acheter ce truc là parce qu'il est
relié à toi c'est toi qui l'a créé et
ils ont l'impression d'avoir un petit
truc de toi chez eux en fait et je
voulais pas qu'ils aient cette
impression avec un objet nul à chier que
j'ai même pas fait moi même là c'est
vraiment un livre qu'on a fait nous
mêmes alors on les aime ou on n'aime pas
c'est normal ça peut pas plaire à tout
le monde mais au moins moi j'en suis
fier et il n'y a rien de mieux que
d'être content de ce que tu as créé de
rendre des gens heureux avec ça quoi
voilà c'est ces derniers mois je suis
aussi passé à la télé tourner la page de
vielles peur qu'aux femmes soient
incapables de savoir comment ça
fonctionne or c'est devenu un métier
donc en 2010 est de regarder des normes
et de la vue des branleurs dans
l'émission messieurs l'allemagne butin
de merde c'est si mal encore même des
mois après c'est faux je peux pas faire
cette vidéo sans parler de ça même si
j'aurais aimé ne pas en parler parce que
ça vaut pas le coup pour faire la promo
de mon livre je lis fallait que je fasse
une télé en gros et du coup on avait
choisi ardisson ce truc-là du mais vous
êtes payés pour jouer à des jeux vidéo
ça avait déjà été exploités par je sais
plus canal + avec deux cônes je crois un
ou deux ans avant et ça avait déjà fait
un gros bad buzz
en fait pour être franc avec vous moi
sur le coup je n'ai pas mal vécue parce
que c'est la télé ça avait très bien
commencé quand ils tuent leur passe à la
télé c'est toujours comme ça que ça se
passe
en fait cette affaire avec ardisson
c'est assez rigolo parce que les gens
ont énormément réagi mais je trouve
qu'en réagissant de manière énervé comme
ça en fait ils ont un peu gagné tu vois
à la télé ils sont 10 ha bah ouais ben
c'est bien ce qu'on pense c'est bel et
bien une petite niche de gamins et dès
qu'on critique un peu ils partent en
furie comme des enfants de 12 ans je
pense la meilleure chose à faire en fait
ça aurait été de montrer ardisson qu'en
voulant faire du buzz en clash en bas ça
marche pas malheureusement il s'est
passé tout linverse a vraiment bien
marché tout le monde en a parlé donc il
a complètement gagné en fait il a réussi
à faire ce qu'ils voulaient faire c'est
à dire faire un petit buzz grâce à un
invité ben mais ce n'était pas un très
bon moment vas-y mito je m'en fous les
gens ils savent ce que je vaux je sais
ce que je vaux c'est pour ça en fait que
sur le plateau j'ai pas du tout mal pris
tout ce qui m'a dit est en tout cas je
vous remercie pour vos nombreux messages
de soutien de courage ça m'a vraiment
fait chaud au coeur même si j'allais pas
mal je m'en foutais complètement en fait
de la prise des missions et je trouvais
ça trop mignon qui on envoie des
messages mais d'un autre côté je me
disais mais merde les gens ils pensent
que je vais pas bien du tout alors qu'au
contraire en fait je m'en fous
complètement en fait de ce qui s'est
passé sur ce truc de télé moi mon truc
c'est net et 6 passes et un truc comme
ça sur ma chaîne youtube là ça me fait
vraiment chier mais à la télé
d'ailleurs certains ont cru que ma vidéo
free style de l'auto dérision c'est en
réponse ardisson mais pas du tout hein
c'était prévu écrit bien avant que je
tourne vers des sons toute la vidéo
entière n'était pas basée sur le fait
que je m'étais fait années chez ardisson
enfin bon les amis voilà c'était ces six
derniers mois sur youtube c'était
intense et f où il ya du gros changement
dans ma vie juste merci parce que j'ai
le meilleur [ __ ] de métier du monde et
pour moi le plus important en fait c'est
de rester sincère avec vous et avec moi
même et de ne pas m'enfermer dans un
truc de pas me mentir à moi-même ne pas
me forcer à faire un truc alors que j'ai
pas trop envie de le faire mais j'ai
peur des réactions des gens donc je le
fais ces six derniers mois ont fait que
j'ai aujourd'hui je me sens vraiment
libéré je me sens vraiment bien tu
beaucoup plus de temps pour moi pour mon
chien et mes amis ma famille j'espère
que la vidéo en 2018 seront encore
meilleurs qui aura encore plus de projet
fou que ça vous plaira encore plus c'est
que de votre côté ce sera pareil que vos
projets vont se réaliser vous allez tout
donner pour et puis je vous souhaite que
du bonheur plein de bonnes choses ça
fait trop du bien de faire cette petite
vidéo et vous parler j'en avais vraiment
besoin je suis pas un modèle mais en
tout cas je vous lis juste mon avis sur
ces six derniers mois sur mon ressenti
perso vous avez dû youtube vous invite
vous et voilà je vous dis à bientôt pour
une prochaine vidéo run année encore une
fois plein de bonnes choses plein de
bisous à vous à vos proches et à il ya
tout le monde
moi je vais me [ __ ] sous ma couette
pour me remettre un peu de maladies
encore merci à bientôt pour d'autres
vidéos plus folles à j'ai des
courbatures bon gars alors 80 piges
[Musique]